President Trump promises to rein in the
power of big tech after Twitter makes
unprecedented moves to interfere in the
presidential election then speaking of
power grabs our de facto president dr.
pouchy seems to be appointing himself
Pope as well by telling churches to stop
giving out Holy Communion Jimmy Fallon
apologizes for a joke he told 20 years
ago Planned Parenthood gets caught lying
about their baby body part business
under oath and finally the mailbag all
that and so much more on Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
I'm not saying doctor foul she is the
Antichrist okay I'm not saying that I
don't want any of you to accuse me of
saying that doctor foul she is the
Antichrist but is doctor foul she the
Antichrist I please let me know your
thoughts in the comments section it's
just look it's weird just to tell the
churches no Holy Communion it's weird
I'm just asking questions I am NOT
saying however that doctor foul Chi is
the Antichrist not saying that we've got
a whole lot to get to first I've got to
thank our friends over at ancestry DNA
you know how much I love ancestry I have
been using ancestry since long before
the daily wire existed my grandfather
turned me on to this he's done a lot of
genealogical research I love it it's
just very very cool you might be
familiar with the major events and
battles of World War two for instance
but there are so many more stories to
uncover in honor of the 75th anniversary
of the end of World War two
ancestry has just released a US draft
card collection from World War two with
over 36 million draft cards completed by
fighting aged men in the United States
across the country during that time
whether they ended up serving or not
there's a great chance that you could
find your relatives in this collection
and it can help you learn more about
what their lives were like check it out
uncover your your ancestors personal
details in the world war ii US draft
card collection which shows details like
home address physical description and
more I love it it's one of my favorite
hobbies you can learn so much more about
you about America's past your past and
yourself
discover your untold stories and more
head to my url at ancestry.com slash
Knowles
to start discovering your story today
that is ancestry.com slash Knowles km
wles big tech has gone too far
way too far we talked about this a
little bit yesterday Twitter is now
fact-checking
Donald Trump on this issue of voter
fraud through the mail and the fact
check is ironic because the thing that
Trump said is actually correct and has
proven out by cases that the DOJ is
looking into and that have been proven
of mail fraud and of voter fraud
rather including mail fraud and it's
ironic because the fax check is not
correct the fact check is this
implication that what Trump said is not
true and what Trump said actually is
true look we've all dealt with big tech
coming after us a little bit okay I
remember on Election Day 2016 I was
barred from Twitter for 24 hours on
election day and it was because I shared
a meme joking about Hillary Clinton and
Hillary voters and they took me off
Twitter for 24 just coincidentally on
election day I've heard this story from
so many people it's true not just on
Twitter but it's true and Facebook and
YouTube right it's happened to all of us
this is different fact-checking the
President of the United States in a
presidential election year on the issue
of voting
especially when Twitter's wrong and
Trump is right it's a big issue it
matters because it means Twitter is
going to interfere in a presidential
election it matters because Twitter is
now telling you that it will no longer
be a neutral platform it will actually
weigh in and tell you what you should
believe and what you should not believe
and it matters because Twitter has just
opened itself up to an absolute
nightmare of double standards for
instance Twitter decided it was gonna
weigh in and fact-check president
Trump's completely accurate statement
about voter fraud in the mail but
Twitter is not going to weigh in at the
same time while President Trump accuses
a morning TV show host of murdering a
staffer and that a little because I'm
willing to admit ok I'm not so blinded
by partisanship I'm willing to admit
that you know maybe Joe Scarborough did
not murder his staffer okay I think I
actually think it's unlikely that Joe
Scarborough is a murderer but that's not
the tweet that's fact-checked it's the
other tweets did Trump tweeted she
tweeted this app is about poor old Joe
the opening of a cold case against
psycho Joe Scarborough was not a Donald
Trump original thought this has been
going on for years long before I joined
the chorus in 2016 when wacky Joe and
his wacky future ex-wife Mika what a
line what
Landon would endlessly interview me I
would always be thinking about whether
or not Joe could have done such a
horrible thing maybe or maybe not but I
find Joe to be a total nutjob and I knew
him well for far better than most so
many unanswered and obvious questions
but I won't bring them up now law
enforcement eventually will if any tweet
is gonna be fact checked probably it
should be this one right but it but it
isn't Twitter is not fact-checking this
because the Joe Scarborough thing is
just a total distraction it doesn't
actually matter right Anza and the line
about the wacky future ex-wife is
extremely funny so that that doesn't
threaten the left Donald Trump pointing
out that what they're trying to do to
voting all across this country is
illegitimate that does threaten the
left's plans and so they're gonna try to
shut it down lots of double standards
and of course there's this this
overarching problem which is that big
tech almost exclusively targets
conservatives so what do we do
Donald Trump has an idea he tweets out
Republicans feel that social media
platforms totally silence conservative
voices we will strongly regulate or
close them down before we can ever allow
this to happen
we saw what they attempted to do and
failed in 2016 we can't let a more
sophisticated version of that happen
again
just like we can't let large-scale
mail-in ballots take root in our country
it would be free for all on cheating
forgery and the theft of ballots whoever
cheated the most would win likewise
social media clean up your act now love
this totally supportive what
specifically should be done some people
say we should do nothing in the name of
some free-market that isn't particularly
free those people are the squishes
they're the ones that do nothing just
let social media control the flow of
information and interfere in a
presidential election that's not a
serious argument some people say we
don't need to pass new laws we can just
enforce the laws on the books this is a
much smarter group of people this is
people like Senator Ted Cruz who says
this they're speaking specifically about
a section of a law from the 1990s
it's called section 230 of the
Communications Decency Act this this
section 230 is what provides what you've
heard of is the
publisher platform distinction so is
this this protection for technology
companies in the 90s to help the
internet grow and what it said was if
you are a platform then you're not going
to be held liable for for the stuff the
content on your platform but if you're a
publisher like a newspaper or a TV
network then you can be held responsible
for those sorts of things I think this
is good we should maybe go down this
road but I think the reality of it is
all of those distinctions are academic
their intellectual distinctions
intellectual games going back and forth
over what a phrase means that basically
misses the point
that's not how laws are actually made
and enforced in this country do you
think that the framers of our
Constitution when they were writing the
Constitution they included a right to
abortion in there but secretly like an
invisible ink that that only couple
hundred years later did a bunch of rogue
lawyers on the Supreme Court figure out
do you think that's what happened no
that isn't what happened do you think
that the founders and the framers
secretly an invisible link included a
right to same-sex marriage monogamous
but not polygamists in the Constitution
and then 250 years later a bunch of
lawyers on the Supreme Court finally
read between the lines in the invisible
ink no of course not do you think that
the First Amendment is always protected
for instance pornography no certainly
hasn't because for most of our country's
history there was no protection for
pornography do you think moving beyond
the Constitution into the law that the
Civil Rights Act protects gender
identity as as certain lawyers or
litigating right now no of course not it
included protections on the basis of sex
there was no conception of gender
identity as we think of it today back
when the civil rights law was passed the
left understands power a lot better than
the right okay that's just the point
there are written laws and there's a
written constitution on the one side
there's also the real practical set of
laws and the real practical Constitution
on the other side okay and sometimes
those have more to do with each other
than at other times
but sometimes they're very separate
this situation with big tech is
unacceptable we cannot allow it to go on
it is a threat to our country it is a
threat to our democratic institutions we
have to stop it however it is stopped is
the way that we should stop it and we
should worry a little bit less about the
intellectual games and the academic
discussions speaking of outrageous power
grabs doctor foul she is now having
already appointed himself president
apparently going to appoint himself Pope
as well we'll get to that one second
first though I got to thank our friends
over at ray con you know having a solid
set of ear buds is an absolute must in
2020 everyone needs a great pair of
wireless earbuds but before you go
dropping hundreds of dollars on a pair
you need to check out the wireless
earbuds from Ray cons
their newest model the everyday e25 year
buds are the best ones yet with six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing
more bass and a more compact design that
gives you a nice noise isolating fit
unlike some of the other wireless
options that you might call we're not
we're look we're not going to name them
here ray con earbuds are both stylish
and discreet with no dangling wires or
stems to distract you during your video
calls they're very very cool they're
comfortable they look great they sound
right now is the best time to get the
latest and greatest from Ray con get 15%
off your order at buy rakin comm slash
knowles that is buy rake on.com slash
nose for 15% off rake on wireless
earbuds buy rake on.com slash your nose
get them you will not regret it it is
2020 you cannot have those dangling
wires anymore rake on Comm slash knowles
so doctor pouchy is being asked as the
country begins to reopen how they should
reopen part of the reason the country is
reopening so soon is because we the
people just refused to accept the new
normal and this state of lockdown for
months and months and years and years
here in LA and in many places around the
country
they said that churches weren't gonna
open up for months churches weren't
going to open up for years and then all
the rest of us said now I don't think so
and then Trump's DOJ said no I don't
think so so now finally they're
beginning to open up the churches but
what dr. Fauci says is we should not
have Holy Communion
we're not allowed to have holy communion
it's you know it's too dangerous as a
direct quote I think for the time being
you just gotta forestall that it's
without she said to America which is a
left-wing Jesuit magazine Catholic
magazine so now the doctor foutch II the
exalted dr. fad she is making not only
our political decisions for us but our
religious decisions as well all in the
name of what you guessed it
science science the overarching
political and religious structure in the
country first of all the lab coats have
no right to make these kinds of
decisions for us okay we like their
advice we're glad that they give us
advice they have no right to be making
these kinds of decisions second of all
the lab coats the experts the exalted
scientists have been wrong even in their
own field even in the very narrow
category of concepts that they can give
us some expertise in they've been wrong
from the very beginning they've been
wrong on how the virus would spread how
bad the virus would be who the virus
would affect have how the virus and when
the virus would go away they've been
wrong about everything but now we're not
only allowing them to dictate our
politics to us we're allowing them to
dictate our religious life to that's
because we've outsourced our politics to
these lab coats and we've outsourced our
religion to them as well that has been a
project of the left going all the way
back to Karl Marx they've they've wanted
government by the by the experts so that
we don't have any debate any longer
because the path to history is so so
clear because there's a progressive
utopia we're all in on the path there's
really nothing to argue about anymore
well that isn't true that project failed
we should take our politics back and
certainly we should take our religion
back and I hope that pastors and priests
and bishops grow a spine and stand up to
this kind of nonsense because well well
doctor foul she might think that man can
live by bread alone mere mere bread
alone
the rest of us know that is not true
speaking of pretending to be things
you're not
Jimmy Fallon you know Jimmy Fallon host
of The Tonight Show formerly on Saturday
Night Live Jimmy Fallon is coming out
and finally apologizing for a joke he
told 20 years ago I kid you not Jimmy
Fallon started trending on Twitter
yesterday or the day before because a
sketch resurfaced in which Jimmy Fallon
did an impression of Chris Rock and when
Jimmy Fallon did the impression of Chris
Rock he darkened his skin and so this
was portrayed as Jimmy Fallon engaging
in blackface which many of his
colleagues have done but they don't get
in trouble for it for some reason we'll
get to that in a moment and so Jimmy
Fallon had to apologize here's the
sketch now we're talking guess what not
a lot of black folks on the show right a
lot of black folks on the show know what
cuz black folks don't like the answer
question oh they want to be booed ass we
gotta ask that kind of questions like
imagine anyone how many grams of crack
did Rick James mostly recorded super
prick
Frieda's do you think the only way to
get a brother on the show the name it
who loves $50 cash in a pair of poopit
okay so first of all first take away
from this it's a pretty good Chris Rock
impression right it is it sounds a lot
like Chris Rock second take away Jimmy
Fallon's not doing blackface he darkened
his skin his face looks black that's not
what black faces okay there are other
left-wing comedians who have done
blackface in this way who don't get in
trouble for it Jimmy Kimmel did he'd be
portrayed Karl Malone and darkened his
skin and put made his face look black
that too not blackface or Robert Downey
jr. the actor he portrayed a white guy
playing a black guy in a movie Tropic
Thunder also not blackface what's the
distinction blackface and the reason
that people are offended by blackface is
when white actors darken their skin to
mock black people that is considered
offensive and it actually has a long
history in the American theatrical
tradition but putting all that aside and
saying obviously nobody's gonna do that
anymore
that is what blackface is doing an
impression of Chris Rock is not doing
blackface because Jimmy Fallon is not
mocking black people generally he is
doing a actually very good precise
impression of Chris Rock
same thing with Jimmy Kimmel as Carl
Malone same thing with Robert Downey jr.
Robert Downey jr. is not doing blackface
he's doing a white guy wearing blackface
to show the absurdity of blackface in
that movie Tropic Thunder not the same
thing and yet Jimmy Fallon apologized he
goes in 2000 while on SNL I made a
terrible decision to do an impersonation
of Chris Rock while in blackface there
is no excuse for this I'm very sorry for
making this unquestionably offensive
decision and thank you all for holding
me accountable oh my goodness gracious
that is so pathetic I get it Jimmy
Fallon just wants to be a nice guy on TV
and be liked by everybody and so he's
going to apologize for these kind of
things
Jay Leno was a little bit like that you
know Fallon's predecessor social justice
warriors here are apoplectic with this
this sort of fake problem I don't Chris
Rock is not offended by this I don't
think most black people are offended by
this I think it's mostly I'm just
looking at the commentary on it I think
it's mostly white liberals who were
offended by this because it's always
white liberals being offended on other
people's behalf they go after Jimmy
Fallon because he's a little bit of an
easy target he's not as left-wing as say
a Jimmy Kimmel so Jimmy Kimmel generally
gets away with it
you know they kick megyn kelly off of
NBC for even mentioning blackface she
mentioned it but Joy Behar who is also
employed by network television totally
fun who she actually wore black
blackface she did she wore a costume as
I think Diana Ross same kind of issue
we're talking about here we did a show a
week or two ago saying that we we have
too few problems in this country this
would be one of them but but actually
this this itself is the problem which is
weaponizing this kind of performed
offended 'no stew take out people that
you don't like even even when this has
not been an issue for 20 years even when
it's you know in some ways it's like
during a political campaign
when assault allegations come up race
racial allegations kind of what whatever
kind of allegations come up you say wait
a second no one's heard about this for
30 years now all of a sudden it pops up
it seems a little bit convenient same
thing here as well and meanwhile though
we have some of these fake problems
meanwhile the worst villains on earth
are getting away literally with murder
and this ties in a little bit with what
we were talking about earlier about the
written law versus the real law Planned
Parenthood just got caught breaking the
law and then lying under oath about
whether or not they broke the law
Planned Parenthood we remember this from
a few years ago Planned Parenthood sold
the body parts of aborted babies for
cash we know they did that that is
against the law that's against 42 u.s.
code
- 89 G - which broadly forbids the
exchange of valuable consideration for
fetal tissue first videos came out 5
years ago you might remember them
it's Planned Parenthood executives
haggling with investigative journalists
who are pretending to be procurers of
baby body parts haggling over the price
one of them joking that she wants a
Lamborghini what would you expect for
intact tissue
what sort of compensation what sort of
one goose tell me what you used to do
[Applause]
[Music]
she's so droll she just wants a
Lamborghini and she knows the first
person who throws out a dollar a number
in a negotiation that's the person who
loses in the negotiation by the way to
buy the body parts of babies that
they've killed so Planned Parenthood
initially denied this even though it was
on camera they denied this I know that
seems crazy but they just went on TV
flat-out denied it they sued the
journalist to expose them for millions
of dollars then a judge who was on the
board of a Planned Parenthood ruled
against the journalists gosh how
convenient is that wonder why he might
have made that decision the Planned
Parenthood claimed at that point was
that they didn't actually sell the body
parts for money
sure they sold body parts and they got
money for it but actually that money was
just a reimbursement for the costs of
giving away the body parts to medical
research here's then president of
Planned Parenthood Cecile Richards
making this claim and lying through her
teeth Washington Post calls Michael
Gerson has pointed out the charging a
fee for this for this material doesn't
not a fee
not a fee it's actually just the cost of
transmitting this material okay that's
her story and she's sticking to it she
made this claim in a lot of other places
so knowing that Planned Parenthood was
gonna lie through their teeth about this
the journalists behind all of this was a
friend of mine David daleiden he emails
Planned Parenthood documents outlining
specific costs for the body parts so not
just saying okay you're gonna reimburse
us for the costs of or we're gonna
reimburse you rather for the costs of
getting these parts no actual dollar
amounts for fetal liver for the thymus
right four different different parts
specifically by the way we're talking
about usable parts so it's not even just
forgetting the parts and then if you
can't use them too bad they are
procuring usable parts just like when
you make a purchase from a department
store and then you know if the product
doesn't work you can go and return it or
not pay for the product same thing here
Planned Parenthood insisted then to keep
the lies going to the New York Times
that they rebuffed a contract to sell
aborted baby livers for 750 bucks each
and $1600 for liver and thymus pairs
however the head of Planned Parenthood
Gulf Coast tram noyon now reveals that
she was in fact looking to move forward
with the deal so so right even after
they get caught with the dollar amounts
they say look we never actually engaged
in the deal we had no intention of
engaging with the deal we now have her
under oath saying she was moving forward
with the deal at just one affiliate
Planned Parenthood Mar Monte the clinic
took in 25 grand in just three months by
selling away baby body parts here is
trim no an under oath admitting what she
did says that the fee to claim her in
Gulf Coast for a fetal liver will be
$750 and the fee for fetal
famous would be $1600 this is an email
chain
between you and don't eat well who is
the regional medical and surgical
services director we understand as Dian
Santos is that your understanding do you
say F we are FYI we're still trying to
move forward with this she responds to
you and says do you want to do this you
respond to her and say yes ma'am do you
remember that exchange yesterday so you
wanted to move forward with the contract
we just saw with those price terms
connection was characterized the
document is characterized the testimony
I think I know I wanted to move forward
with it I know I wanted to move forward
with it we have her admitting it we have
them under oath we have it in writing we
have the dollar numbers we've got these
guys dead to rights violating the law
but this gets to this point earlier
earlier on this gets to this point about
big tech and so many other facets of our
politics Planned Parenthood is probably
not gonna be held accountable do you
think Planned Parenthood's gonna be held
accountable for this no way actually
probably the journalist is is gonna
continue to get in trouble
the journalists probably gonna be forced
to pay millions of dollars have his life
thrown into chaos even more so because
there's the law as it's written down and
then there's the practical law is the
Constitution as it's written down then
there's the practical Constitution and I
think sometimes even people on the right
get a little too confused about this
they get really worked up because they
say look the law is so clear look I can
point to the law sure who's going to
enforce it who's going to enforce it
planned parenthood commits crimes
against humanity crimes against the
natural law crimes against the actual us
code crimes every single day many many
many times a day they don't get in
trouble for it because we as a society
have chosen to embrace them through
ridiculous Supreme Court decisions
multiple Supreme Court decisions through
ignoring parts of the law and through
going after people
who are exposing those violators of the
law that's that's an unfortunate reality
but that's the way politics always works
we're only going to go along with the
sort of laws that we want to go along
with right we are a self-governing
people we live in real real time and
space with real desires same thing with
big tech does section 230 of the
Communications Decency Act establish
this condition that the social media
companies have to be politically neutral
yeah maybe it does maybe it doesn't I
don't know that that was not the point
of the law when it was passed is that an
effect of the law it should be an effect
of the law it's only going to be an
effect of the law if we do something
about it the left gets this the left
gets that they've got to get into the
institutions that they've got to move
the the levers of power that they've got
to worry less about academic debates and
more about actually affecting what they
want in the world conservatives need to
wise up to that a little bit as well
because there's nothing good and
wonderful and virtuous about frittering
away all of our time on academic
disputes well we lose the actual power
to govern and affect our agenda in the
country speaking of the difference
between the imagined world and the real
world you gotta turn to the New York
Times which is the official paper of
record of the imagined world you know we
talked yesterday about the Karen meets
Karen and that that altercation in
Central Park between the woman walking
her dog and the creepy guy luring her
dog away with treats and filming her so
there's a piece in the New York Times
that gets this situation I think exactly
backwards it's called a white damsel
leveraged racial power and failed this
is by Ruby Hammad Ruby Hamad is the
author of white tears Brown scars how
white feminism betrays women of color so
you can kind of get this lady's
perspective opening line the symbolism
is almost too much to bear the
antagonist stares down the barrel of the
camera removing her surgical facemask at
the same moment she takes off her
figurative facemask and offers the
audience a glimpse
what lies underneath the woman Amy
Cooper points her finger at the stranger
behind the camera Christiane Cooper to
demand that he stop filming her when he
refuses she threatens to call the police
and then immediately acts on her threat
this woman is portraying this as a bad
thing if a man is filming a woman in a
park against her will that woman should
call the police she maybe you shouldn't
get so hysterical about it and she
shouldn't do some of the other things
that Amy Amy Cooper did but the guy was
in the wrong the guy started it he acted
like a weirdo and a creep and he
wouldn't go away and it's very bad so
bad situation this woman immediately
fused and of course it was this man's
right to film this woman how dare she
suggest that she would call the cops but
then you get the money in line at the
end this is this is the real line for
threats to mr. Cooper have significance
in a society that regards black men as
persistent threats to women it's not a
society we're talking about we're
talking about this guy being a weirdo
around this woman which he undeniably
was they are a brutal reminder that
whatever the actual substance of their
dispute she knew that a single cry for
help could bring down the weight of
white supremacy on his body this is what
we talk about when we talk about the
violence of white woman's tears except
that didn't happen
right that what this woman is asserting
is that Amy Cooper knew that with just
one call on her phone she could bring
down the weight of white supremacy on
this black man's body it's very odd they
always talk about bodies they don't talk
about the whole person I think it's
because they're materialists now and the
only view the body is mattering but
that's not what happened actually the
woman made the call and then the weight
of our actual culture destroyed her life
not his life she lost her job she lost
her dog they took her dog away even she
lost any reputation she had and the guy
is totally fine he's fine he's a hero he
is being exalted as a great man for
creepin up on a woman
and luring her dog away with treats and
filming her against her will
he's the good guy in the story according
to the pop culture and the woman had her
life ruined regardless of what they
actually did that's the effect on the
culture and yet the narrative that the
New York Times tells themselves is this
is a white supremacist country that is
constantly hunting down young innocent
black men LeBron James says black men
can't walk out the door without being
hunted down that isn't true
that just simply isn't true there there
are rare incidents that become
sensationalized precisely because
they're so rare but the real culture not
the one that you read about the New York
Times but the real culture actually is
the opposite of that this this woman's
life was destroyed for her damsel in
distress cries this guy doing totally
fine now you would think that this woman
would actually be happy about that right
because it shows we don't have a white
supremacist country in that a good thing
now the left can't ever be happy with
any of those things that they want
because the criticism the complaining
the narrative is the whole point before
we get into the mailbag I do quickly
have to have to knock Jack Dorsey Jack
Dorsey's the head of Twitter Jack Dorsey
is very upset that some of us after this
fact check on president Trump after
Twitter decides to weigh in on a
presidential election and interfere in
it we've pointed out that the head of
Twitter's site security a young guy
whose tweets have now been coming up
hates Donald Trump hates him calls Trump
an actual Nazi where's the fact check on
that as says that the people in the
middle of the country are more or less
useless because they've elected a racist
tangerine as he said so this guy's
getting a lot of play Jack Dorsey comes
out and says fact check there is someone
ultimately accountable for our actions
as a company and that's me please leave
our employees out of this will continue
to point out incorrect or disputed
information about elections globally no
you won't you're just doing it on Trump
not on his opponents and we will admit
to and own any mistakes we make no
you're not admitting any mistakes you
make you're just upset that we're going
after your
who's the head of site security you know
whose fault it is that people are going
after that employee
Jack Dorsey's fault that's whose fault
it is Jack Dorsey put that employee in
that situation when he chose to weigh in
to a presidential election I don't want
to go after this kid I don't care I
don't care that even the head of
Twitter's site and Taggart not site
Security site integrity rather that's a
sort of Orwellian term but he's he is on
the department that is going after these
fact checks I don't care that this guy
hates Donald Trump it it actually
doesn't even bother me what bothers me
is the Twitter's interfering in the
presidential election that's not this
young employees fault that's Jack
Dorsey's fault Jack Dorsey should own it
he should change course ASAP and then
finally there is a major story that is
developing right now as we speak in
relation to one of these awful stories
about an unarmed black guy who was
killed because the police appear to have
been way too heavy-handed in making an
arrest as a result of this now there is
looting in Minneapolis where the arrests
occurred there's there's rioting going
on in Los Angeles for some reason you
can see the looters there videos of them
going all around the internet you can
see the looters in Minneapolis just
robbing a Target store yeah so just poor
you know pouring in pouring out stealing
a bunch of stuff I have a hot take on
this Hut take is looting is bad that's
my hot take I know controversial looting
is bad
obviously police brutality if that's
what occurred here looks like it did
that's very bad too there are
investigations into that Donald Trump's
DOJ is now investigating that he says
justice will be served that's a good
thing there's there's no excuse here for
looting doesn't look good and in Los
Angeles but what I was looking at some
of the looting it looks like some of
them aren't even the BLM protesters who
are rioting it's actually an Tifa I
would recognize those pallid little
socialists anywhere there seem to be
other groups involved as well
tragic that a man died good that there's
an investigation civil society is a
delicate thing
that's my big takeaway on big tech on
Polk pouchy on Jimmy Kimmel almost
getting canceled 20 years later on on
all of these things on the looting civil
society is a delicate thing it's not so
simple as we have a constitution we have
a set of laws everything is going to be
hunky-dory
because there it is it's written down
it's not so simple as we be we've
behaved in certain ways in the past so
now we'll be fine there's there's no
amount that we can exert on our society
that will crack it it's delicate it's a
civil society can be broken by corrupt
officials it can be broken by corrupt
businessmen maybe in big tech it can be
broken by corrupt people who go looting
it can it can be broken we are now in a
position where we are being encouraged
mostly by the left to break that society
why does the progressive left want to
break the society is they don't like the
society that much that's why their
presidents say they want to
fundamentally transform that society
that's why they engage in criticism all
the time of that society trying to
progress forward into the future if you
want to conserve any of that society
then you've got to be careful we've got
to be a little bit more delicate with
our institutions with our traditions and
with each other we'll get to the mailbag
in one second first though I've got to
thank you and I've got to tell you to
head on over to the Michael Noel's show
YouTube channel if you're watching this
on youtube right now you might not be
aware that there's a whole other channel
which is my shows channel you probably
watching it on The Daily wire but on my
channel we release some bonus content
some bonus interviews that kind of thing
yesterday we released a bonus segment on
everyone's favorite new Trump appointee
Kayleigh mcenamey absolutely wrecking a
mainstream media reporter also known as
leftist operative it's a good time also
to let you know you got the one tumbler
when you sign up for the daily wire well
guess what you get now you get two
tumblers but you got to sign up for our
most exclusive membership tier all
access the all-access tier is our
premier level of membership
you know you get everything you get you
get me you
get more of the ben shapiro show you get
QAS exclusive editorials and add free
website experience but none of that
matters you get two tumblers head on
over get 15% off right now with coupon
code Knowles Cana wles join all-access
daily wire.com / subscribe coupon code
Knowles save 15% we'll see you there
we'll be right back with the mailbag
running late as usual but there's just
too much to get in so let's fly through
this mailbag from Shane Michael do you
find it a coincidence that once again
during a presidential election year the
media is playing the America and
Americans are racist narrative just
recently you had the are brie and MS and
mr. Karen racist event in like a one
week stretch do you see this as being
artificially hyped up for the election
and do you think it is a calculated play
to make these issues borderline racists
so the Dems can automatically call the
people involved racist while the right
waits for more information which allows
the left to call us racist and not not
for minorities seems like the tried and
true Democrat strategy to me do nothing
to help minorities then play up
so-called racist incidents every four
years to retain the vote thanks yeah
that is going on that is going on
unquestionably I mean you saw the
article we just read it in the New York
Times which is actually concocting this
narrative which was contradicted by
reality but consider this they're I
think they're about 55 homicides in the
United States every day actual full-on
homicides
all of those homicides are not reported
on there they couldn't be right you just
there just isn't enough time to report
on them and it's not newsworthy when 55
of them happen every day only certain
stories become sensationalized into
these national news stories pushed
relentlessly by the mainstream media who
work for the left who work for the
Democratic Party the selection of those
stories is the key here because those
stories are selected to advance a
particular narrative I'll give you an
example if the if the if the mainstream
media wanted to be racially divisive the
other way around what they would do is
play up that video that was going a
little bit around social media of a
black elder facility worker punching
repeatedly in the head there's an older
white man in his bed that was going
around the internet now is that
indicative of a broad systemic issue of
Elder Abuse and and specifically racial
elder abuse is there an epidemic of
young black elder care workers beating
up these older white I don't think so I
don't think there's any evidence of that
but if the me
stream media wanted to craft a narrative
that they was what they were that there
that there was such a thing going on
they would play that video again and
again and again and again but they don't
do that obviously because it doesn't
serve their political agenda they do
however take these rare sensationalized
stories of racial discrimination or
abuse in the other direction and play
them again and again it is a form of
political and emotional manipulation it
is highly effective I mean it's lowdown
and rotten to do it but it is very
effective that is why they keep doing it
and they're not just doing it this time
they're gonna do in another four years
and another four years after that
from David hey Michael my question is
how do you defend the national motto
which I personally agree with In God We
Trust as constitutional while I agree
with it I can't quite seem to be able to
justify it as constitutional and within
the power of the federal government
thanks so much well by definition its
constitutional and within the power of
the federal government in that we have
from the very beginning of our country
acknowledged God's role right we we
acknowledge the role of Providence on
our own currency the very founding of
our country was by Christian religious
zealots on the Mayflower there were
prayers at the beginnings of Congress
and all of our founding fathers almost
all of them had a deep and abiding faith
so of course it's constitutional I mean
what how would what what is more
constitutional the kind of arbitrary
interpretation of the Constitution that
some secular leftists have today or the
way that the founders and framers
thought about the Constitution obviously
the latter is there's a big
misunderstanding about church and state
in America people believe that the First
Amendment separates completely church
and state first of all that isn't
exactly true what the First Amendment
does is prohibit the establishment of a
religion at the federal level but
actually just because there's no
established church at the federal level
does not mean that there cannot be
established churches at the state level
and actually the time of the
ratification of the Constitution there
were established churches at the state
level not just not rather at the federal
level and then moreover freedom of
relate
freedom to have your own churches at
least as a federal matter is not freedom
from religion it was never considered to
be that way that is absurd this country
was founded as a shining city on a hill
the the founders and framers said
repeatedly John Adams very clearly that
the country is only built for a moral
and religious people it is unfit to the
governance of any other kind of people
I'm gonna take their word for it over
you know the the random neckbeard
atheist who who insists that his own
narrow reading of the Constitution is
the correct one actually this ties into
the point we were talking about today
you could with sufficient hubris and
sufficiently context-free interpretation
read almost whatever you want into the
Constitution and into our laws but that
won't do you very much good that doesn't
actually ground you in what it means
you've got to read it within context and
then moreover the real political fact of
it is our Constitution is going to mean
what we want it to mean I mean we hope
that we can govern ourselves more and
more like the document tells us to and
and more and more with the institutions
that the document sets up but in reality
there is there is the actual lived
practical Constitution and it looks a
little bit different than the written
one and unfortunately that real
Constitution that we live under looks
like it's trending in the wrong
direction from Ken dear mr. Knowles
knower of all that is right why do you
and your family continue to live in
la-la land could you do your show from
say Florida or Texas or some other more
conservative state thanks I suppose I
could I don't know why I couldn't you
know we just build a studio and do the
show from somewhere else I do like the
idea of living in a liberal place
because I'm a masochist I've always
lived in liberal places New York
Connecticut Los Angeles there is
something that you know gives you a bit
of an edge when you live in a left-wing
place it just lets you see the leftist
culture more
clearly but Newsom and Garcetti and all
these other people are quickly making
these places unlivable you know I really
like the sunshine and the nice weather
and the palm trees but if they if they
keep clamping down on us you know if
they won't let us go to church or
something like that then maybe we'll
have to pick up and move left to pull an
Elon Musk and get out of Dodge
all right final question from bird named
three people living or dead you'd love
to interview Winston Churchill certainly
he would probably be the most fun to
interview we could smoke cigars and and
get hammered while we paint and talk
about you know all of the things that
not only wins Nutritionals saw on
experience but also wrote about let's
not forget he wrote the history of the
english-speaking peoples probably had a
lot to talk about Dante certainly I
would want to meet and talk to Dante and
get his religious vision and his
artistic understanding and then probably
Christopher Columbus because he's so
controversial now and he's so essential
to our civilization to the to the
Americas to the expansion of the West
and he's so often misrepresented that
I'd like to get his side of the story I
think he'd be pretty pretty interesting
dinner guests as well those are the
three guys just off the top of my head
that is our show we'll have other things
for you we will have verdict podcasts we
will have more and more over the weekend
but that's all for this show so if I
don't see you before then in the
meantime I'll see you Monday I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20/20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there